well after months of controversy
surrounding unlv's nickname and mascot
today
we have answers sports director chris
matthews joins us live with more on
what the school president revealed today
chris well thank you very much this has
really been a hot topic for years and
really heated up over the last year or
so
what to do with the school's nickname
and mascot remember earlier this year
they already took down the mascot hey
reb so it's gone
and there are no longer any logos of the
mascot on any football or basketball
jerseys
the mascot controversy dates back to the
70s when they had a confederate themed
mascot then for 10 years
unlv didn't have a mascot in 83
the hay reb was introduced and as of
today the mascot is now gone
earlier this summer we caught up with a
former rebel who anticipated changes at
unlv
but he says he'll always be a rebel a
running rebel
you know it's a lot of change that's
been happening you know uh
for them changing the logo from all the
way to
knocking down the hey rep you know
mascot this is
you know the changes has been almost
something every year
so i'm kind of getting used to it but
you know at the end of the day you know
you don't know you running rebels that's
that's what it is man it's been like
that
since i've known it all right and that
will not change unlv president keith
whitfield making the announcement today
that unlv will keep the nickname of the
school
rebels but that the mascot is gone and
as of now the school will be the only
school in the west
without a mascot might be the only
school or franchise in las vegas without
a mascot
even from elementary school all through
high school in the pros
seems everybody now has a mascot except
for
unlv hey if you'd like to chime in on
this issue go to our eight news now
facebook page and leave your thoughts
as of about an hour ago nearly 600 votes
68 percent want a key pay rep 32 percent
say
they don't need hey reb